un mot sur votre état d'esprit nous
sommes à 24 heures du début de l'examen
de la réforme des retraites ici à la
Chambre haute comment est-ce que vous
sentez
celui qu'on a à chaque fois que on
aborde un débat et ça c'est un débat
important c'est un débat important parce
que c'est sans doute le seul débat qui
impacte chaque Français et moi ce que je
souhaite c'est que le Sénat donne une
autre image que c'est le cas donné
l'Assemblée nationale ici c'est le
sérieux c'est pas la guignolisation et
je crois qu'il faut aussi que on puisse
voter voilà justement la gauche qui a
fait une conférence de presse à 14h qui
est très offensive elle dit que et bien
il y a maintenant une seule majorité
entre la majorité sanatoriale et la
majorité présidentielle que pensez-vous
de leur position politique de leur
stratégie aussi qui est d'examiner
l'article 7 mais de ne jamais aller au
bout de l'examen du texte à la fin ça je
suis pas d'accord du tout ici notre job
c'est pas discuter à l'infini
c'est de discuter pour éclairer un débat
mais surtout pour éclairer une
délibération c'est-à-dire un vote est-ce
que ça veut dire que mes collègues
considèrent que l'article 7 et le seul
important que l'usure professionnelle
l'invalidité les travailleurs handicapés
les petites retraites on devrait pas les
discuter et les voter non ça c'est de
l'obstruction et c'est du blocage il y a
11 jours au total d'examens du texte ici
à la Chambre haute weekend compris
est-ce que la droite et le centre vont
faire l'usage d'outil du règlement à
l'image de cet article 38 du Règlement
des snap que de contraindre les débats
est-ce que vous prenez l'engagement de
ne pas utiliser cet article de règlement
vous voulez rire est-ce que en face on
prend l'engagement parce que mes
collègues de gauche prennent
l'engagement de ne pas recourir au
blocage alors si vous irez recours
monsieur
ce sont des instruments qui sont
démocratiques et je considère que le
blocage est une entorse à la démocratie
un mot sur votre rencontre vous étiez
matinion avec Gérard Allah chez le
président du Sénat ainsi que le chef de
fil des centrist Hervé Marseille entre
midi et 13h30 une heure de rencontre que
s'est-il dit
ce que nous avons toujours dit voilà sur
nos priorités on veut une réforme qui
soit une réforme pour quelque chose pas
pour rien un équilibre notamment en 2030
on veut qu'on considère enfin la
situation des maires de famille parce
que la réforme se fait d'abord sur leur
dos voilà donc j'ai rappelé les
fondamentaux et nos lignes rouges et
alors justement la réponse de la
première ministre
par exemple sur ce que vous vouliez pour
les femmes cette effectivement cette
aide pour les femmes qui ont eu des
enfants on n'a rien te payer du tout
mais j'ai bien senti que le gouvernement
centraux ouvert de toute façon il y a
pas le choix
sans cette ligne là qui est une ligne
rouge pour nous sans ce point-là jamais
nous ne voterons une réforme ni
maintenant ni en CMP ni après allons
dans le détail un tout petit peu plus
encore si vous le voulez bien article 1
concerne les régimes spéciaux la
Commission n'a pas prévu d'aller plus
vite ou plus loin que ce qui était prévu
dans le texte initial du gouvernement on
sait que certains LR peut être vous
souhaitiez et bien qu'il les amendements
qui aille dans ce sens avec plus de
suppression de spéciaux ou plus
rapidement est-ce qu'il y a de la
friture sur ligne avec les centristes et
c'est ce qui explique qu'on n'avait pas
plus loin non pas du tout non non ça
fait partie des marqueurs de notre
groupe et je veux rappeler que le fameux
amendement qui a déterminé
l'architecture de cette réforme 64 ans
et 43 à l'unité et bien chaque année
nous votons vous le vérifierez dans
cette amendement une convergence sur 10
ans des régimes spéciaux donc que
personne ne soit surpris c'est important
bien sûr puisque je ne vois pas pourquoi
une seule catégorie de Français
s'affranchirait des efforts que tous les
Français devront faire un dernier mot
sur un point précis du texte les
carrières longues on y comprend plus
grand chose pour être tout à fait
honnête avec aussi parce qu'il avait été
voilà convenu avec Monsieur Pradier
qu'est-ce que vous allez du coup voter
sur les 43 annuités pour les 40 les
carrières longues la demande la demande
notamment de d'Éric Ciotti et d'Olivier
Pradier à l'Assemblée nationale qui
s'était exprimé
Olivier Marleix pardon qui s'est exprimé
notamment au moment des questions
d'actualité c'était Véronique louvagi
qui avait porté cette question et
c'était Elisabeth borde qui lui avait
répondu c'était pour la création d'une
quatrième borne d'âge pour les carrières
longues à 21 ans bien ce point-là nous
en serons solidaires ensuite il y a une
surenchère permettez-moi de dire que on
n'est pas nécessairement solidaire avec
la surenchère mais sur cette quatrième
Board on sera solidaire j'ai une
dernière question elle concerne Aurélien
Pradier sur France Inter et la critiqué
ce qui se joue avec l'entente entre LR
et le gouvernement il a dit précisément
la seule chambre parlementaire qui
représente le peuple c'est l'Assemblée
nationale les sénateurs ne sont pas les
représentants du peuple qu'est ce que
vous répondez au député du Lot j'ai rien
du tout de relire la constitution de la
5e République
oui vous n'avez pas on est dans un
régime de bicamérissent que vous rien
prédire
les objectifs personnels ça le concerne
vous allez pas à chaque fois coréen
Pradier s'exprime je vais pas me
positionner sur les commentaires de
Monsieur Pradier commentez les
commentaires
par rapport à ses sorties je trouve
qu'héritier a été courageux il a déjà
tapé du point sur la table je voudrais
peut-être réciter une très belle phrase
de Victor Hugo parlant justement du
bicamérisme il avait dit Victor Hugo que
la France gouvernée par une assemblée
unique ce serait l'océan gouverné par
l'ouragan c'est beau il a été sénateur
Victor Hugo et bien c'est sur cette
citation que Staline s'est interview
Merci à VOUS Bruno Retailleau d'être
venu sur le micro Public Sénat
[Musique]